hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream wir freuen uns sehr dass ihr bei
uns seid heute vor genau 9 Monaten hat
der russische Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine begonnen heißt auch 273 Tage
läuft dieser völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg jetzt genau aktuell sind
vor allem am Boden die Regionen im Osten
der Ukraine schwer umkämpft da sind die
Regionen dann jetzt und luansk und aus
der Luft da treffen russische Raketen
immer wieder auch das sehen wir gerade
eingeblendet zivile Infrastruktur sie
zerstören ganze Wohnhäuser Straßen
reißen da alles auf sie trennen auch
ganze Regionen von der Strom und auch
Wasserversorgung ab
und das ist auch bekannt sie löschen
wahllos Menschenleben aus gestern
ukrainische Angaben die wir da gehört
haben sie sprachen von mindestens sechs
Toten nach den Attacken waren auch heute
noch große Teile der Hauptstadt Kiew
ohne Strom und auch viele Menschen sie
hatten keinen Zugang zu fließendem
Wasser den ganzen Tag über das aber sei
laut Bürgermeister Klitschko
mittlerweile jetzt zumindest wieder
hergestellt also die Wasserversorgung
für die Bevölkerung wieder da das soweit
die Meldungen von heute Mittag
Oberst Markus Reisner ist heute vom
österreichischen Bundesheer bei uns zu
Gast der ist erfahrener Militärexperte
unter anderem auch aus eigenen
Auslandseinsätzen z.B im Kosovo Krieg
guten Abend Herr Reissner danke für Ihre
Zeit
wir haben gerade Herr Reisner die Bilder
zusammen gesehen die Zerstörung die
angerichtet werden durch die russischen
Raketen und sie kommen durch woran liegt
das gerade dass die Ukraine diese
Raketen offenbar nicht abwehren kann
ja die Herausforderung besteht darin
dass nach neun Monaten Krieg befestigen
müssen dass es die Russen durchaus noch
Fähigkeiten haben die wir bis jetzt
unterschätzt haben eine Beispiel dafür
ist der Einsatz von arschlochkörpern
ballistischen Raketen und eben auch
iranische Drohnen gegen Ziele der
kritischen Infrastruktur wir haben
Monate lang und zwar eingeredet dass die
russische Luftwaffe kaum Einsätze fliegt
dass diese Präzision so Körper und
Raketen eine sehr geringe Treffer
Wahrscheinlichkeit haben aber es hat uns
die Wirklichkeit mit Ende September
Anfang Oktober eingeholt nämlich in dem
Moment entschieden hat die kritische
Infrastruktur anzugreifen das zentrale
Nervensysteme die Stromversorgung die
das Land und seine Bevölkerung brauchten
diese geschützten Bereiche entsprechend
der Flieger der
zu schützen um also die Voraussetzungen
zu schaffen dass diese kritische
Infrastruktur nicht zerstört ist und die
haben jetzt mehrere Aspekte die zum
Tragen kommen der erste Aspekt ist das
die russische Luftwaffe am Beginn des
kriege jetzt ca bereits ein Drittel der
ukrainischen Flieger der zerstört hat
die Flieger dabei wurde dann in weiter
Folge auch eingesetzt zum Schluss zu der
Bereitstellungsräume für die offensiven
die wir dann in der Eule Anfang August
und den weiter vorgesehen Oktober
gesehen haben
im Oktober mit ihrem marschallkörpern
und der ballistischen Raketen die Ziele
der kritischen Infrastruktur anzugreifen
hatte die Ukraine kaum mehr
fliegerbesysteme und sich dagegen stehen
zu können es ist dann dazu gekommen dass
die ersten System eingetroffen sind aber
die Schere Größe des Landes und auch die
Objekte die hier zu schützen werden
macht es fast unmöglich jetzt etwas
dagegen zu tun und das Ergebnis sehen
wir jetzt aufgrund der Angriffe
insgesamt mittlerweile 11 Fällen seit
Mitte Oktober bis jetzt ja wir sehen
also das Sprechen sie ganz klar an das
Problemfeld dass dieses Thema ja nicht
genügend vorhanden sind und das auch
Nachschub Mangel besteht an Munition für
die Systeme das halten wir fest für den
Moment Dankeschön Herr Reisner wir
vertiefen diese Probleme auch was es in
Sachen Logistik zu beachten geht sie
haben gerade die Größe der Ukraine
angesprochen später weiter in der
Sendung auch wie diese Probleme
womöglich den weiteren Kriegsverlauf
beeinflussen können was habt ihr für
Fragen an Oberst Reisner stellt die
gerne direkt in die Chats oder auch per
Mail Adresse kommt da haben wir sie ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de und natürlich gerne
auch alle Fragen die reinkommen an
unseren zweiten Gast heute mit dem wir
jetzt gleich sprechen und das ist
Roderich Kiesewetter von der CDU von der
Opposition im Deutschen Bundestag er ist
Mitglied im Auswärtigen Ausschuss des
Bundestags mit ihm sprechen wir über die
Waffenlieferungen aus Deutschland und
was dabei seiner Ansicht nach auch
schief läuft
gutes Stichwort schauen wir da auf den
Bereich der Artillerie laut
Nachrichtenmagazin Spiegel hat das
deutsche Verteidigungsministerium bei
den Lieferungen der Panzerhaubitze 2000
das wurde der Ukraine geliefert nicht
aber die Lieferung von Ersatzteilen
dabei bedacht Marco Jessen der hat genau
das heute mit dem
Verteidigungsministerium besprochen und
diese Antworten für uns herausgefunden
die Panzerhaubitze 2000 eine hoch
willkommene vielleicht eine
entscheidende Waffe in den Händen der
ukrainischen Armee 14 davon hat
Deutschland an die Ukraine geliefert um
das Land im Krieg gegen Russland zu
unterstützen das Nachrichtenmagazin
Spiegel berichtet jedoch viele seinen
inzwischen nur noch bedingt
einsatzbereit weil Ersatzteile fehlen
würden bei der Instandsetzung in Litauen
hätte eine der Haubitzen ausgeschlachtet
werden müssen um die anderen
gefechtsbereit zu halten anders das
deutsche Verteidigungsministerium es
verweist darauf dass bereits Ersatzteile
für die Haubitze geliefert wurden und
die Wartung wäre ab Mitte Dezember
einfacher dann müssen ja sitzen nicht
mehr umständlich nach Litauen gebracht
werden sondern können direkt hinter der
ukrainischen Grenze in der Slowakei
repariert werden dort wird gerade einen
instandsetzungszentrum aufgebaut es soll
noch vor Weihnachten einsatzbereit sein
Versicherte die verteid Finanzministerin
letzte Woche in Brüssel wir werden in
der Slowakei ein instandsetzungszentrum
einrichten das kann sofort losgehen die
Vereinbarung ist getroffen es ist eben
wichtig all das was all das was
geliefert wird auch nach dem Kampf
wieder instand gesetzt werden kann mit
allen Mitteln werden wir auch in Zukunft
die Ukraine unterstützen ob aus den
Beständen von Bundeswehr und Industrie
auch genügend Munition für die deutschen
Waffen in die Ukraine geliefert werden
kann dazu hält sich das
Verteidigungsministerium bedeckt das sei
auch eine Frage des Kriegsverlaufs
also bei den entscheidenden Fragen
weiter
unbeantwortete Fragen Roderich
Kiesewetter ist jetzt bei uns für die
CDU im Deutschen Bundestag guten Abend
Herr Kiesewetter grüße sie guten Abend
Herr hoch grüße Sie Herr Kiesewetter
warum ist dort also sie sind auch
Mitglied im Auswärtigen Ausschuss des
Bundestags das sei noch dazu gesagt
Frage an Sie warum ist Deutschland bei
den Nachschublieferungen so schwer
fällig gerade nun das spielt natürlich
eine ganz große Rolle dass sehr früh
bereits Forderungen kam Ersatzteile zu
bestellen und vor allen Dingen Munition
und das nicht umgesetzt wurde des
weiteren sind unsere
Einsatzgeräte also auch die
Panzerhaubitzen oder auch marswerfer ja
wie soll ich sagen den Übungsbetrieb in
Deutschland gewöhnt aber hier wird die
Waffe jeden Tag rund um die Uhr
ausgenutzt die Munition dafür fehlt da
wird andere Munition herangezogen das
gibt besondere Verschmutzungen und das
alles hätte im Vorhinein mit einer
klugen Aufklärung schon gelöst werden
können hinterher muss man immer schlauer
aber was mir fehlt ist das frühzeitige
zu erkennen wir haben die Monate März
April Mai verstreichen lassen als die
Entscheidung fiel dass die
Panzerhaubitze 2000 geliefert wurde
verging ja auch noch sechs Wochen der
Ausbildung und da hätte man spätestens
die Bestellungen treffen müssen aber wir
brauchen ja nicht nur Munition oder
Ersatzteile sondern auch durch den hohen
Verschleiß Rohre die Rohre haben eine
sehr lange Lieferzeit also hier kommt
sehr viel zusammen man hat es einfach zu
blauäugig zu spät entschieden ja die
entscheidende Frage ist ja aber wenn man
das doch hätte absehen können warum
wurde nicht langfristig und auch
perspektivisch gedacht und gehandelt von
Seiten der Bundesregierung auch ich will
ja als Oppositionspolitiker keine
Vorwürfe machen ich war selbst 27 Jahre
bei der Bundeswehr und bin Oberst außer
Diensten und habe mal einen Raketen
Atelier Bataillon geführt mit 32
Raketenwerfern und da liegt natürlich
auch der Hase im Pfeffer wenn man sich
auf den Krieg vorbereitet muss man
wissen dass man eben nicht wie auf einem
Übungsplatz vielleicht vier fünf Mal
schießt sondern jeden Tag 50 80 90
Granaten abfeuert oder auch
entsprechende raketenzahlen und die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat ja allein
in der Belieferung der Munition das ist
nachzulesen zwei Tagessätze geliefert
die Ukraine verbraucht am Tag etwa 5 bis
6000 Schuss Adri Munition und geliefert
wurden zunächst einmal 13.000 Schuss und
weitere 6000 angekündigt das heißt es
sind gerade mal drei bis vier Tage an
Munition mitgeliefert worden das ist
längst verbraucht das hätte man wissen
müssen und zweitens durch den hohen
Verschleiß frühzeitig die erforderlichen
Ersatzteile die ich jetzt hier nicht mit
Fachbegriffen nennen will bestellen
müssen all das muss vorgehalten werden
gut ist dass wenigstens ab Mitte
Dezember dieser
instandsetzungshub aufgebaut wird aber
das werden alles Entscheidungen die man
früher hätte absehen müssen und dann
sage ich das ist ein tatsächlicher
Vorwurf und das wäre im Mai oder Juni
bereits eindeutig absehbar gewesen weil
man ja weiß die Ukraine hat am Tag
Munition für 5 bis 6000 Granaten und die
Russen haben im Gefecht knapp 50 bis
60.000 Granaten und da ist doch klar
dass die Ukraine ihre Geräte auf
Verschleiß fährt und sich einfach darauf
verlässt dass sie ordentlich unterstützt
wird und da haben wir zu viel
versprochen und zu wenig gehalten was
die Ukraine auch fordert aus dem Westen
aber auch aus Deutschland ist ja wie sie
es geradeaus sagen länger schon
schwere Kampfpanzer weitere Systeme zur
Luftabwehr die Probleme die haben wir
auch gerade schon mit Opas 30er gesehen
und besprochen
sie sagen die Ukraine sie sagen diese
Waffen diese westlichen Systeme von
NATO-Partnern von Deutschland die würden
eben auch entscheidend sein um diesen
Krieg weiter zu beeinflussen und auch
perspektivisch zu gewinnen
jetzt hat Herr Reisner bei uns auch
schon angesprochen die Logistik ist ein
Problem und auch die Instandsetzung das
haben sie gerade thematisiert mit dem
instandsetzungshub warum genau kriegen
wir es nicht hin diese Waffen die
gefordert werden auch an die genau
richtigen Stellen dann zu liefern also
an die richtigen Stellen werden sie ja
geliefert was allerdings bei uns nicht
gemacht wird und ich nenn erstmal was
gemacht wird wir haben fünf
Raketenwerfer Mars gesendet und wir
haben 14 Panzerhaubitzen gesendet dann
haben uns noch die Niederländer
unterstützt das ist sehr wenig wenn man
weiß dass die Amerikaner um die 100
Stück geliefert haben und vor allen
Dingen ähm einige hundert Haubitzen also
sind wir schon mal von den Zahlen sehr
niedrig natürlich verlassen sich die
Ukraine auch auf unsere Unterstützung
insbesondere auf die Panzer bitte 2000
was aber benötigt wird ist durch die Art
der alten sowjetischen Waffensysteme
Kampfpanzer und Schützenpanzer haben die
wenn die einen einen Treffer erleiden
keine Überlebenschancen sind die
Soldaten oder ein explodiert das Gerät
und erhitzt auf bis zu 8000 grad da
verdampft alles das ist ganz furchtbar
wenn dem Schützenpanzer Marder 4050
Jahre alt und Kampfpanzer Leopard 1 auch
etwa 40 50 Jahre alt eine viel bessere
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit haben das
Verteidigungsministerium ist da in der
Pflicht des Kanzleramts aber das
Außenministerium das
Wirtschaftsministerium während für die
Lieferung genauso wie die Liberalen und
Grünen sich sehr deutlich für die
Lieferungen ausgesprochen haben wir
unterstützen das wir haben als Bundestag
mit fast 600 Stimmen 586 stimmen die
Lieferung schwerer Waffen bereits am 28
April unterstützt er scheut sich das
Kanzleramt diese Systeme zu liefern das
unterscheidet man nicht mit westlich
oder östlich sondern die sind einfach in
der Lage den Besatzungen ein Überleben
zu garantieren und dass wir das den
Ukrainern vorenthalten liegt daran dass
sich Deutschland bedroht fühlt und dass
man glaubt dass Russland bei einer
solchen Lieferung nuklear eskalieren
würde und das ist falsch und das müssen
wir auch sehr öffentlich ansprechen dass
hier Russland mit der deutschen
angstarbeitet ohne das wirklich
umzusetzen wir müssen Mut sein und der
Ukraine den Sieg ermöglichen und wenn
die Ukraine nicht ihre Grenzen
wiederherstellt darüber hinaus darf es
nicht gehen zumindest vom Januar dieses
Jahres dann wird die Ukraine zerfallen
und der Krieg wird weitergehen gegen
Moldau wird weiter gegen gegen das
Baltikum und deswegen ist die Lieferung
dieser Waffensysteme so bedeutend
Deutschland meldet Führungsansprüche an
ja Führung heißt auch europäisch zu
koordinieren die Amerikaner ermutigen
uns schützen und Kampfpanzer zu liefern
weil wir hier die Logistikketten haben
13 Nationen haben den Kampfpanzer
Leopard also die Bundesregierung sollte
ja nicht verzagen sondern auf FDP und
Grüne hören und auch vielleicht auf den
einen oder anderen Rat aus der Union
also klare Forderungen hier von Ulrich
käsewetter an die Linie des Kanzleramts
mehr schwere Waffen zu liefern für die
Ukraine Herr käsewetter ich nehme ganz
gerne jetzt unsere Community auch mit
rein die stellt persönliche Fragen auch
an sie es geht um folgende Situation
noch mal ganz kurz zu den Fakten
Deutschland wollte ja auch offenbar das
waren die Pläne 12.000 Schuss Munition
für den Flugabwehr Panzer Gepard liefern
der wird ja ich brauche jetzt gerade in
der Ukraine für für den für die
Bekämpfung der Drohnenangriffe der
russischen Seite eingesetzt die Schweiz
hat es untersagt die Munition
weiterzusenden Begründung Neutralität
die Frage an Sie ist vom User Till Meyer
bei Youtube gestellt sprechen Sie sich
jetzt dafür aus die Schweiz dafür zu
sanktionieren keine Gepard Munition zu
liefern und die beurteilen Sie generell
den Komplex also bei so einem Krieg kann
man nicht neutral sein das ist völlig
klar und die Schweiz hat von ihrer
Neutralität über Jahrzehnte durch
Milliarden Investitionen auch aus
Russland von Oligarchen profitiert die
Schweiz ist ein echter kriegsgewinner
und schiebt die Neutralität vor die
12.000 Schuss sind in Deutschland
stationiert aber wir werden diese
Schweizer Munition nicht verwenden wenn
dieses Land nicht von sich selbst darauf
kommt viel wichtiger ist es dass wir die
200.000 Schuss gepartmunition die aus
Brasilien kommen und jetzt gerade in
Katar sind zum Schutz der
Weltmeisterschaft dann hoffentlich
weitergehen und dass diese Munition
produziert wird Deutschland hat die
Daten für die Produktion nach Norwegen
und auch in die Ukraine gegeben so dass
das vor Ort produziert werden kann der
Krieg bedeutet ein Krieg gegen uns alle
Russland möchte nicht dass die
Europäische Union und die NATO so
weiterleben wie bisher sie werden für
Massenflucht sorgen und greifen zivile
Infrastruktur an deshalb wäre
departmunition so wichtig um die sehr
billigen iranischen Drohnen die jeweils
so 40-50 Kilogramm Sprengstoff haben und
Elektrizitätswerke zerstören so wichtig
diese abzuschießen und deswegen sage ich
auch sehr offen Neutralität hilft hier
nicht weiter hier geht es um schwerste
Kriegsverbrechen an der ukrainischen
Zivilbevölkerung das ist kein
militärischer Krieg mehr sondern ein
Vernichtungskrieg gegen das
Existenzrecht der Ukraine klare
Statement halten wir so fest
sie waren genau vor einem Monat auch
selber persönlich noch mal vor Ort in
der Ukraine ziemlich genau glaube ich
sogar drei Wochen vor drei Wochen sie
haben sich vor Ort ein Bild gemacht
vielleicht können sie uns da noch mal
Eindrücke schildern welche Probleme
haben sie in Sachen Munition Logistik
und Transportwegen entdeckt und was
braucht es aus ihrer Sicht noch das
festzuhalten um diese Probleme auch für
den weiteren Kriegsverlauf zu lösen nur
sehr kurz ich habe vorweg auch sehr viel
das Leiden der Zivilbevölkerung gesehen
Stromausfälle Wassermangel Luftalarm
erlebt wir waren in Kellern also da ist
schon ein Krieg gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung was es braucht ist
schlichtweg mehr Nachschub mehr
Produktion deshalb ist es gut dass die
Bundesregierung sehr rasch einen Gipfel
mit der Rüstungsindustrie Macht zur
Produktion von Munition von treib von
von entsprechenden Mitteln um
batteriegranaten zu verschießen also von
Pulver und Sprengstoffen das ist
überfällig wir brauchen hier mehr
Fabriken nur die Bauzeit und Lieferzeit
wird anderthalb Jahre zwei Jahre
bedürfen deshalb recht sich jetzt dass
wir keine Vorräte haben und deshalb
müssen wir alles tun Partner zu
überzeugen zu liefern des Weiteren geht
es darum mit der Ausbildung frühzeitig
zu Beginn beispielsweise mit den Fahrern
von Marder oder Leopard aber auch die
Ausbildung an entsprechenden Geräten zu
verbessern die Instandsetzung zu Verb
und der Ukraine Produktionsmöglichkeiten
zu schaffen im eigenen Land wo wir eben
schlichtweg mithelfen dass die
Produktion produziert werden kann das
war auch eine ganz dringende Forderung
und eben noch einmal die Bitte nach
alten Kampfpanzern Leopard und nach
alten Schützenpanzer Marder weil die
schlichtweg besser sind als das sehr
gefährliche sowjetische Material das
auch ausgeht ich möchte Ihnen noch
einige Kommentare mit auf den Weg geben
die aus unserer Community kommen die
gehen in die ähnlichen Forderungen wie
sie sie auch beschreiben von Thorsten
schlabbeck bei Youtube der deutschen wir
sind ein so reiches Land wir müssen viel
mehr helfen sagt er und einen Kommentar
da würde ich sie auch ganz gerne noch
mal nach ihrer Einschätzung fragen ob
sie das auch so sehen jerk Simplon fragt
bei Youtube oder schreibt bei Youtube
als Kommentar warum nicht langfristig
und vorausschauend geplant wurde weil
man in Deutschland mit 30
Bedenkenträgern aus diskutieren muss
wenn man einen neuen Bleistift schon
kaufen will gehen sie damit ist das auch
Teil der Problematik also ein Teil der
Problematik ist das in der Bundeswehr
führungs- und materialverantwortung
getrennt sind die materialverantwort das
Zivil für das neudeutsch heißt
outgesource dieses zivilvergeben und die
Truppenführer haben nicht mehr die
materialverantwortung wie ich selber
noch als bataillonskommandour sie hatte
das zweite ist dass die Ausschreibungen
in Deutschland anders als in Frankreich
erst europäisch erfolgen Frankreich
schaut erst was können Sie selbst
leisten und drittens hat Deutschland
leider das berührt auch die
Regierungszeit der Union
Produktionskapazitäten heruntergefahren
und der Koalitionspartner war allerdings
damals auch der Bundesfinanzminister der
heutige Kanzler also hier ist vieles im
Argen deswegen helfen parteipolitische
Überlegungen überhaupt nicht sondern wir
müssen auf Kriegswirtschaft umstellen im
Bereich der Rüstungsindustrie und das
heißt Arbeitszeitregelungen und anderes
durch bessere Bezahlung überlagern und
alles tun dass wir Produktionsketten
aufbauen wo binnen Monaten
Kanonenrohre Munition aber auch
Kleinwaffen und vieles andere mehr
geleistet wird um diesen Krieg zu
gewinnen ich kann den Kommentaren nur
zustimmen wir sind zu bürokratisch zu
langsam
haben uns nicht darauf eingestellt dass
wir Kriegsziel Russlands geworden sind
eine Mischung aus Selbstkritik der
eigenen Regierungsverantwortung und
klaren Forderungen aber auch an die
aktuelle Bundesregierung vielen Dank
Roderich Kiesewetter von der CDU
Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestags und
auch Mitglied des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses
wir sprechen jetzt weiter bei uns im
Stream wie entscheiden der aktuelle
nachschubmangel den wir festgestellt
haben für den weiteren Kriegsverlauf
sein kann und das besprechen wir weiter
jetzt mit Oberst Reissner vom
österreichischen Bundesheer bei uns
schönen guten abend noch mal Herr
Reisner die erste Frage die sich da
natürlich noch mal stellt ist wenn wir
über Bestände nachschubmangel sprechen
vielleicht können wir festhalten gibt es
eine Prognose wissen Sie wie lange die
aktuellen Munitionsbestände der Ukraine
noch ausreichen
eine derartige Prognose kann man jetzt
nicht stellen wenn man nicht über die
genaue Lagerbestände natürlich
bescheiden ist von beiden Seiten aber
lassen Sie mich vielleicht etwas
ergänzen zu dem vorhergesagten das
wichtige dass man verstehen muss und da
muss man weder Militär Experte sein noch
Militärstrategie oder sonstige
militärische Ausbildung haben aber wenn
man versucht das einer
Friedensorganisation einen Krieg zu
führen dann kann das nicht funktionieren
und genau das ist das Problem während
Russland sich vorbereitet hat Monate
möglicherweise Jahre sind das alleine in
der schieren Anzahl an Abgeordneten
Raketen am arschlochkörpern über 4700
sind da mittlerweile gegen die Ukraine
eingesetzt worden und auf der anderen
Seite Europa sich in keiner Art und
Weise vorbereitet hat im gegen 20 Jahre
seine Streitkräfte abgerüstet es hat
alles eine Lage leer gemacht und jetzt
versucht man mit demjenigen quasi eine
Frau zu versorgen und das funktioniert
natürlich nicht der denken sie alleine
daran die Frauen dann der gekämpfte in
der Ukraine ist
1100 km lang das wäre so wenn sie in
Berlin ins Auto steigen und auf London
fahren und dann können Sie sich
vorstellen was ihre 14.00 einsetzen oder
mehrfach Raketenwerfer das geht sich
einfach nicht aus
den Krieg kann man nur führen wenn man
wirklich massiv mit aller Anstrengung
die dazu möglich und notwendig ist
entsprechend sich
bindet und auch versucht eine
Veränderung herzustellen indem man
massiv hier Unterstützung leistet und
das ist nicht der Fall das ist alles ein
Tropfen auf den heißen Stein und die
leeren sich laufend die Ukraine hat die
offensiven jetzt im Sommer nur
durchführen können weil sie bereits
schwere Waffen aus dem Westen bekommen
hat das war also vor allem 400 der
Kampfpanzer sowjetischer Bauer das Polen
Bulgarien Tschechien und anderen Staaten
das Material dass sie selber hatte und
eine hatte die quantitativ stärksten
Streitkräfte Europas das war zu diesem
Zeitpunkt bereits abgenutzt diese Waffen
haben mir jetzt quasi es möglich gemacht
Person hackiv ist dieser Räume besitzt
zu nehmen aber auch das wird wieder
verbraucht die Frage ist wo sollen die
nächsten Systeme herkommen aber wenn wir
jetzt von den deutschen Leopard reden
das dürfen nicht vergessen diese Systeme
vom Papier z.B die wurden in den letzten
Jahren alle ausgeschlachtet der schaut
so aus wie ein Panzer von außen aber das
ist nichts mehr drinnen das muss alles
wieder was sie hochgerüstet werden diese
Platine aus den 80er 90er Jahren die
werden noch gar nicht mehr gefertigt das
ist alles Hand Manufakturen entstanden
Europa ist auf diesen Krieg nicht
vorbereitet gewesen und ist es auch
jetzt noch nicht einmal versucht einfach
mit kleinen Lieferungen dass das Leid
und die Not zu lindern aber wir sehen an
diesen Angriff in der kritischen
Infrastruktur wenn er sich hier nicht
massiv fliegt ab jetzt Verfügung
gestellt wird dann ist in wenigen Wochen
die Ukraine komplett finster weil es
keine kritische Infrastruktur mehr gibt
die funktioniert
okay aber was braucht es dann an der
Stelle wenn sie sagen man war nicht
vorbereitet man ist es auch jetzt noch
nicht was sind Lösungsweg aus ihrer
Sicht ja man müsste eine massive
Anstrengung vollziehen und man müsste
tatsächlich in den Wirtschaftssystemen
beginnen also massiv für eine
rüstungskapazitäten wieder aufzubauen
die Rüstungsindustrie ist natürlich zu
zurückhaltend man möchte Garantien haben
von den Staaten von den politischen
Führerschein sagen also wir können euch
garantieren die Abnahme von so und so
viel Stücke raten dieser Munition diesen
Waffensystemen dann ist man bereit diese
Investitionen zu tun es ist ja nicht so
dass wir von einem Moment auf anderen
stampfen können das dauert es am Monate
und das aufzubauen und da möchte man
natürlich ganz sicher sein dass auch das
was Investition ist die sich lohnt auf
die Dauer weil sie können nicht im
Prinzip was das also gratis oder so ohne
Bezahlung da jetzt einfach von Rüstung
sind dass die verlangen dass sie wieder
hochziehen soll
hier rennen uns natürlich die Zeit davon
das ist das Problem weil wir haben weder
die lagebestände die wir
zwischenzeitlich liefern könnten an die
Ukraine um dann was entsprechend die
Rüstung im Hintergrund hochzufahren noch
einmal die Kapazitäten dass wir also
quasi massiv jetzt beginnen entsprechend
dieser Bauvorhaben umzusetzen oder die
fertigungssträngen und so weiter instand
zu setzen diese wie sie sich einmal
gegeben hat das heißt das Problem ist
nur versucht zusammen zu kratzen was man
hat und das zu liefern stellt fest dass
es zu wenig ist schaut sich irgendwo
findet man Neues und versucht das wieder
zu liefern und das ist das Problem der
heilige hinterher während Russland das
wäre Monat für Monat tot gesagt haben
und die Arme nicht ernst genommen haben
und zeigt dass es auf der strategischen
Ebene nämlich ganz und die strategische
Abnutzung geht jetzt wieder in die
Initiative geht und das ist das Paradoxe
wir haben auf der operativen Ebene
Erfolge der Ukraine die aber durch die
strategischen Angriffe der Russen zu
nicht gemacht werden die Ukraine sitzen
den Personen aber sie sitzen im Dunkeln
dort die Russen die Infrastruktur
zerstört haben sie hinterlassen
einerseits verbrannte Erde andererseits
zerstören Sie ganz gezielt dieses
Nervensystem der Versorgung der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung jetzt sagt der
britische Geheimdienst aber auch das
Russland massive und dramatische
Nachschubprobleme auf der anderen Seite
auch habe was sind da ihre Informationen
und das Russland Probleme hat das Hören
jetzt seit Beginn des Krieges gerade vom
britischen Nachrichtendienste und sie
dürfen nicht vergessen wir führen einen
Krieg im Informationsraum hier geht es
also ganz Ziel darum Beeinflussung fakt
ist dass Russland es bis jetzt geschafft
hat auf dieser strategischen Ebene ein
Momentum aufrecht zu halten und dieses
Momentum bedeutet dass man immer die
Russen ist entscheiden es zu einer
Angriffswelle gegen die Ukraine kommt
und machen das ja schlau sie schicken
zum Beispiel mehreren schwärmen zuerst
die iranischen Drohnen die griechische
Flieger wird gesättigt sie versteht ihre
Raketen und dann kommen die Arschloch
Körper die dann doch überraschenderweise
sehr präzise ihre Ziele treffen also 750
KVA
transformieren genau das ist das Problem
wo sind diese russischen
Lager auch langsam leer werden wenn Sie
daran denken dass zum Beispiel S300
Raketen als Boden bodenraketen
eingesetzt werden oder eben das
erscheinen diese iranischen Drohnen aber
das ist ja das verheerende denn das
erscheinende iranischen Drohnen zeigt
dass die Russen es rechtzeitig geschafft
haben dafür vorzusorgen dass ihre Lehrer
den Lager sich nicht bis zur Gänze
leeren sondern sie haben das kompensiert
mit dem Einsatz dieser iranischen
Drohnen und wir hören dass
möglicherweise weitere Sorten kommen
oder sogar iranische Raketen geliefert
werden das heißt das Momentum kann
aufrecht erhalten werden während auf der
anderen Seite diejenigen verfügbaren
eigenen ukrainischen Luftabwehrsysteme
immer weniger werden weil sie die Ziel
angegriffen werden aber auch die
Munition ausgeht Munition die sie so
nicht mehr finden in der Ukraine und
auch nicht gefährdet in Europa darum
muss man quasi auf europäische Systeme
oder amerikanische Systeme umstellen und
auch hier sind die Lager sehr begrenzt
das ist das ist das Problem dass wir
hier gerade sehen das ist ja auch genau
die Forderung aus der Ukraine dass man
eben langfristig komplett auch auf NATO
Systeme und Prozess auf festliche
Systeme umrüsten möchte und eben nicht
auf die sowjetischen Bestände die man
durch den Krieg erbeutet das heißt aber
wie wenn ich sie höre und wenn ich das
richtig verstehe sehen Sie schon die
Gefahr eines kritischen Punkts auch für
die Ukraine im weiteren Kriegsverlauf
wenn diese Umrüstung jetzt eben nicht
nachkommt und wenn die weiteren
Lieferungen ausbleiben
natürlich wir sind also auf dem Weg zu
einem coolerationspunkt wir haben uns
geweigert diesen kombinationspunkt
anzuerkennen deshalb bereits am Beginn
des Krieges stattgefunden wir wollten
sie nicht diesen abnutzungskrieg wahr
haben man hat also von Woche zu Woche
gehört dass die Russen werden nächste
Woche zusammenbrechen das war nur
zwischen Sieg sie sind also nicht in der
Lage diesen das zu tun trotzdem besitzen
so immer noch knapp 18 % des
Territoriums graben sich gerade ein und
sind auf dieser strategischen Ebene in
der Lage Initiative zu zeigen durch
diese Angriffe auf die kritische
Infrastruktur und die Frage ist wer
erhält das jetzt länger durch die
Ukraine die also was ich hier stetiger
abgenutzt werden oder die Russen auf der
anderen Seite soll sich das
Satellitenbilder an sie haben sogar
seine dunkle Ukraine und ein heller
leuchtetes Moskau das ist das Garantie
dafür dass Russland quasi unbeschadet
aus dem Vollen schöpfen kann während die
Ukraine weil sie kämpft darum zumindest
im kleinen Rahmen Unterstützung zu
bekommen aus dem Westen oder auch aus
Amerika würde Amerika nicht liefern
by the way dann wäre der Krieg
vermutlich schon vorbei weil wir kommen
was haben was wir in Europa quasi zur
Verfügung stehen können das ist die
traurige Wahrheit im Wesentlichen wenn
man eine Anzahl von ihres t-systemen da
liefert die nicht einmal die die Anzahl
der Finger nach Hand betrifft dann
können Sie sich vorstellen was in diesem
riesigen Land schützen können was solche
Rakete 700.000 Euro kostet im Gegensatz
zu 20.000 $ iranischen Drohne und so
groß sind unsere Lage bestehende nicht
weil wir ja nach dem Ende des Kalten
Krieges gedacht haben
das Ende der Geschichte ist angebrochen
wie francisana gesagt hat und alle
unsere Waffensysteme und alle Dinge die
wir quasi gesagt haben die nicht
brauchen abgerüstet haben es gibt keine
Lagerbestände mehr die müssen erst
aufgebaut werden das dauert Jahre die
Frage ist ob die jahrelang durchhalten
kann oder nicht
apropos durchhalten gibt es aber auch
noch
weitere Stimmen auch von Kollegen von
Militärexperten und eine weitere
Hochrechnung auch was das
Durchhaltevermögen auf russischer Seite
angeht die kommt vom Kollegen Markus
Kolb er ist Militärexperte der ETH in
Zürich und er hat eine Hochrechnung
aufgestellt und sagt dass die aktuellen
Zahlen sagen wenn wir mit Blick auf
Artillerie und Panzer schauen dass die
russische Armee schon 1000 Panzer
verloren habe und aktuell auch fünf
Panzer pro Tag verlieren würde der sagt
das sei eine so hohe verschleißquote wie
in keinem Krieg zuvor und wenn das so
weitergeht das ist auch seine
Hochrechnung dann hätte Russland in
einem Jahr gar keinen Panzer mehr können
Sie das bestätigen das wäre dann ja aus
ukrainischer Sicht ein ein
entscheidender
gut aber die Frage ist wenn da die
Russen in einem Jahr gar keine Bahn zu
mehr haben was haben dort was haben zu
diesem Zeitpunkt die Ukraine haben die
auch diese mehrrate und quasi ihre
entsprechende Verteidigungsfähigkeit
oder sogar in den angeführer gehen zu
können das ist die große Frage und sie
dürfen nicht vergessen die russische
Systematik der Einsatzführung und auch
der Art und Weise des Einsatzes der
Waffensysteme war eine völlig konträre
andere zu der des Westens der besten hat
sich darauf konzentriert hochpräzise
moderne Waffensysteme zu bauen die mit
einer Vielzahl von Sensoren eine
Überlegenheit auf den Gefecht wird
darstellen russland hat immer auf das
Gegenteil gesetzt es hat versucht durch
Masse
eingefecht zu entscheiden wann nimmt
also an für einen eingegebenen Panzer
also ein Panzer der quasi geschützt
steht braucht man ungefähr vier
angreifen
dazu braucht man also vier die 72 3
werden abgeschossen werden aber der
vierte wird diesen Leoparden knacken das
war die Idee das war die Idee der Masse
des masseneinsatzes und wir sind das
auch hier dann Stanzer die die Russen
hier einsetzen sind zum Teil Systeme aus
den 50er 60er Jahren diese t260 Systeme
zum Beispiel er vereinigt alles was ein
Panzer braucht in diesen Gefechten wie
wir sie sehen er ist beweglich er hat
Feuerkraft und er hat Panzerung es muss
kein moderner T14 sein also die letzten
Modelle von denen die Russen einige
wenige haben es reicht dieser alte Band
aus den 50er 60er Jahren um genau diesen
Effekt zu ziehen und da hat Russland
noch sehr sehr viel auf Lager und wenn
es offensichtlich in der Lage ist mit
dem Iran einen Deal zu machen und drohen
zu bekommen bei weiß mit dem man sonst
noch einen Deal macht und auch Panzer zu
bekommen und wenn dieser Nachschub
ununterbrochen weiterlauft und wenn auch
die Bevölkerung weiter zum Regime stehen
also wenn es keine Oktober 1917 Moment
gibt und wenn dir das Wissen trotzdem
Weiterkommen da wird Russland durch
diese Schere Masse einfach ein Faktor
sein der für die Ukraine ein riesen
Problem darstellt wenn die Ukraine nicht
von außen unterstützt wird weil es hat
mal einen eigenen ähnlichen Bestand der
sich nur sehr sehr langsam auffüllt
durch die Lieferungen des Westens also
auch einmal die klare Forderung an den
Westen nach weiterer und tatkräftiger
Unterstützung sie haben das gerade im am
Anfang ihrer Antwort thematisiert so die
Frage ist wer hat das zu welchem
Zeitpunkt auf beiden Seiten und auch da
will ich Ihnen ganz gerne noch mal eine
weitere Einschätzung von Herrn Kolb
sagen er prognostiziert was den Bestand
der Artillerie angeht gerade auch wie
Sie das sagen noch eine Überzahl auf
russischer Seite er sagt aber wenn jetzt
eben Schritt für Schritt die
nato-systeme die westlichen Systeme
nachgeschoben werden dann sieht er schon
dass sich das in vier Wochen auch kippen
könnte auf Seiten der Ukraine deckt sich
das mit ihren Berechnung was würden Sie
sagen wie wird sich das entwickeln das
wird natürlich von der nähere abhängen
mit dem der besten quasi hier die
Ukraine mit Waffensystemen unterstützt
sie müssen sie vorstellen die Ukraine
hatte Streitkräfte die natürlich
grundsätzlich in der letzten Jahre acht
Jahre aufgerüstet worden sind passieren
ob ehemalige sowjetische System
22 oder 152 mm hier haben die Ukraine
Millionen von Granaten verfügbar gemacht
diese Granaten sind alle bereits mit
Masse verschossen darum muss der Westen
jetzt massiv eigene artilleriesysteme
nachschieben weil also hier noch ein
Kaliber vorhanden ist das im Westen der
Standard war das 155mm Kaliber und mit
dem versucht man dann wieder diese
handschuhversorgung durchzuführen wir
haben im Sommer gehabt den Zustand dass
auf russischer Seite am Tag ca 60 bis
70.000 Granaten verschossen worden sind
von ukrainischer Seite ca zwischen 20
und 25.000 Karten das ist am Tag sind
also dort 100.000 Granaten verschossen
das ist die haben Millionen von Granaten
die verschossen worden sind wenn sich
die Bilder anschauen das dagegen von
Pack Mut oder von
artemisco oder von der Solidar dann
sieht das aus wie in der Teil 1916 oder
in isson 1917 also eine Qualität der
Kriegsführung die wir nicht für erwarten
Möglichkeiten haben und ich gebe Ihnen
ein Beispiel für die Lager noch im
Kombination mit dem was sie am Anfang
gehört haben in das Krieges nach
mehreren Wochen haben großen circa 530
marschflowkörper ballistische Raketen
eingesetzt der Westen hat unisono gesagt
die Nachrichtendienste das wird ja wohl
gewesen sein weil so viel haben die
Amerikaner damals 2003 beim einmachim
Irak eingesetzt im Juni des Jahres waren
wir bei 2.800 im August bei 3.500 und
jetzt vor kurzem herr Präsident selenski
gesagt über
4.700 marschflugkapitalistische Raketen
und iranische Drohnen wurden eingesetzt
das gab es bis jetzt noch nie in der
Kriegsgeschichte und wir wissen nicht
wie er diese Lager sind also ich wäre
sehr vorsichtig mit dem Prognosen das
sind ein paar Wochen alles vorbei ist
und ich würde mich darauf vorbereiten
dass dieser Krieg sehr lange dauert und
dass wir versuchen müssen wenn wir
wollen dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnen sie massiv zu unterstützen das
heißt wir müssen unsere Rüstungsbetriebe
wenn es sie nicht gibt anwerfen und
versuchen hier das zu produzieren was
die Ukraine braucht
sie haben auch gerade den Ort im Osten
der Ukraine angesprochen Bach Mut können
wir vielleicht ganz kurz auch noch mal
die Karte zeigen wo wir das Ganze vor
Orten
da ist der Frontverlauf und da blicken
wir dann auch auf basmut sie haben
gerade beschrieben was sie dort für
Bilder gesehen haben vielleicht können
Sie uns dann noch mal sagen was sind da
gerade für Kämpfe wie entwickeln die
sich und warum ist dieser Ort gerade so
hart umkämpft und was passiert da
dazu müssen Sie verstehen dass der
tonbass eine besondere Bedeutung hat und
zwar noch aus dem Jahr 2014 heraus dort
waren diese erste Kämpfe in den
Separatisten Gebieten dort erfolgte da
einmal der russischen Streitkräfte am
Nationalfeiertag am 25 August 2014 da
gab es auch dann diese
waffenstillstandslinien das Ergebnis von
minsk-zug die Ukraine hat in den Jahren
nach 2014 über 40% seiner
Landstreitkräfte in dompass konzentriert
und diese Lautstärke haben sich acht
Jahre lang auf diesen Angriff der Russen
vorbereitet die Ukraine hat immer gesagt
die Russen werden wieder kommen der
Westen wollte es nicht wahrhaben Ukraine
hat dort drei tief gestaffele
Verteidigung Stellungen eingerichtet
Verteidigungsstellungen die können Sie
im Ausbau vergleichen zum Teil wie mit
dem atlantikwahl was in der Normandie
1944 und diese Verteidigungsstellungen
versuchen die Russen zu durchbrechen mit
dem Ziel auch den oblastung jetzt zu
gehen sie einzeln zu nehmen sie haben
drei Stellen geschafft die erste Linie
zu durchbrechen das war im Sommer bei
passner das war diese Kesselschlacht von
diese Chance
Ausmaß von 40 von 40 x 40 km sie haben
es auch geschafft bei pisky vor kurzem
und der Marinka und erscheint
möglicherweise auch bei backmodus dabei
sind wenn sie das schaffen sind sie
quasi hier durch die erste Linie durch
und stehen vor der zweiten Mini ihre
Hoffnung ist auch die zweite und dritte
Linie zu schaffen und dann in das offene
Land vorstoßen zu können bis jetzt ist
ihnen das nicht gelungen sie marschieren
aber immer noch langsam und stetig vor
zwei in einem sehr sehr geringen Umfang
aber mit dieser massiven Artillerie
Unterstützung gelingt ihnen das nach wie
vor es gibt zwar immer wieder
Rückschläge wie zum Beispiel durch den
Einsatz amerikanischen heimat-system im
Sommer wo dann diese Munitionsdepot
diese umfangreichen zerstört worden sind
aber auch hier hat sich Russland
angepasst und hat diese Munition
aufgelocker das heißt es kann das
Momentum wieder weiterfahren und
Russland hat sich kontrolliert im Süden
durch die Rücknahme der Kräfte bei
Person eigentlich vergleichbar mit einer
Situation
1940 das ist die Russen haben hier
30.000 Mann unbeschadet über den Nebel
genommen haben sie sich auf die starke
Südseite zurückgezogen konnten Kräfte
freisetzen bis jetzt zentral einsetzen
südlich von saporoscia und dort einen
Stoss was in der Ukraine Richtung
militopol aufzuhalten aber vor allem sie
haben ihre Elite Verbände von die
falsche mega nun verfügbar um sie
möglicherweise im Dom was einzusetzen
und dort den Druck weiter zu erhöhen das
heißt die Problematik besteht darin dass
die Ukraine jetzt wieder in einem
Fegefeuer sich befindet im bombas in
diesem abnutzungskrieg indem sie schon
im Frühjahr Sommer hineingezogen worden
ist dazu kommen auch weitere Kommentare
und Fragen auch aus der Community die
würde ich dann gerne an der Stelle
einbauen zum Beispiel vom User denken
dann handeln er sagt wenn sie gerade
eben diese Situation ansprechen besteht
gerade auch nicht nur ein Mangel an
Nachschub sondern auch ein Mangel an
Soldaten in der Ukraine um das dann auch
zu lösen wie würden sie das einschätzen
ja das ist die nächste Herausforderung
die wir haben man muss ja sagen dass
Europa in der Ukraine bis zum letzten
Ukraine kämpft das kann man genauso
ansprechen das heißt die Ukraine ist was
den Einsatz der Soldaten betrifft dass
ich alleine gestellt und jetzt stellen
Sie sich vor Sie haben auf der einen
Seite 144 Millionen Volk Russland dass
ein theoretisches Potenzial hat von 30
Millionen Reservisten der sogar
eingesetzt werden kann von denen es
jetzt begonnen hat hunderttausende zu
rekrutieren und es sind nicht diese
2300000 Möglichkeit viel viel mehr im
Dezember und jänner dann davon ankommen
auf der anderen Seite haben wir die
Ukraine wenn man die geflüchteten Weg
rechnet ein 35 Millionen folgt das noch
im Land sich befindet wo mittlerweile
die fünfte oder sechste je nach Zähler
hat Mobilisierung stattfindet das ist
jeder bis zum Alter von 60 Jahren wird
eingezogen
und wenn es jetzt nicht zu einem
schwarzen Schwan Moment kommt also quasi
einen disruptiven Ereignis auf
russischer Seite oder gar auf
ukrainischer ist wenn ich daraus sagen
können ist es eine reine numerische
herunter ein reines numerisches
herunterrechnen wann sich das nicht mehr
ausgehen kann alleine von der Anzahl der
Soldaten da können Sie noch so viele
Waffen liefern wenn die Ukraine keine
Soldaten mehr haben dann wird es einfach
schwierig werden und darum ist auch so
entscheidend dass je länger man zuwartet
und die Ukraine nicht unterstützt desto
größer ist quasi die Abnutzung dieser
Soldaten gegen gerechnet gegen das was
Russland was in den Kampf führt und
damit ist die Zeit so entscheidend zu
Unterstützung der Ukraine und das sagt
die Ukraine auch aber wir stehen ein
bisschen ratlos herum und beamen immer
noch die Situation dass wir in diesem
Konflikt sind die mir nicht voraus sind
konnte so sagen wir ja die ganze Zeit
und auf dem wir uns nicht vorbereitet
haben der hat uns einfach eiskalt der
Brust und jetzt ist der hier die Vorrede
des Krieges und sie geht nicht weg das
ist das Problem
auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch die
Meldung und Berichte die wir sehen dass
auch die russische Armee natürlich
Verluste erleidet und auch Reservisten
in den Krieg schickt auch das steht dann
wieder im gegenüber und auch da
wahrscheinlich einfach dann wieder die
Frage wie sich das weiterentwickeln wird
wahrscheinlich ne natürlich die
russische Armee hat massive Verluste ich
ich zitiere hier eine sehr prominente
Stimme general Miley den
us-generalstoffchef der hat vor kurz
zwei sehr interessante außer angetroffen
die erste Aussage war gesagt russland
hat bis jetzt ca 100.000 Mann
angefallenen und verbundenen erlitten
eine schier unglaubliche Zahl er hat
aber auch gesagt auch die Ukraine und
das war das erste Mal dass in diesem
Form des öffentlich gemacht worden ist
hat dieselbe Zahl an Soldaten dass sie
durch Toten Verwundung verloren und dann
hat er noch gesagt 40 bis 50 000
Zivilisten sind ebenfalls gefallen ja
und er hat darauf hingewiesen dass der
Erfolg der Ukraine bei Person
möglicherweise die Chance für
Verhandlungen bieten könnte aber er hat
das erste Mal Zahlen wirklich in den
Mund genommen und stellen sie mir vor
wir haben also innerhalb von neun
Monaten mehrere hunderttausend Tote und
Verwundete erlitten das gab es in dieser
Qualität schon lange nicht mehr und es
ist nicht irgendwo wo es uns nicht
interessieren kann wie in Syrien oder
sonst wo sondern es ist direkt an der
Grenze Europas Europa ist jetzt
gefordert die Werte auf die es so stolz
war entweder zu verteidigen oder sich
RAS zu entscheiden wie man diese hier
weitermachen ja absolut jetzt sprechen
Sie an vielleicht die Chance der
Verhandlungen auch da Fragen aus der
Community von nemodo sollte man dann
nicht eben jetzt vielleicht
Friedensverhandlungen anstreben statt
permanent auch über Waffen und das
weitere entwickeln zu sprechen das ist
eine politische Entscheidung
die europäischen Staatsführer auch ins
gemeinsam mit der Amerika muss ich hier
müssen sich hier durchringen und sagen
entweder wir gehen diesen Krieg bis zum
Schluss im Kampf oder wie entscheiden
wir können es nicht und beginnen mit
Verhandlungen was wir jetzt tun ist
zögern zaubern Zweifel und nicht wissen
wie wir hier weitermachen sollen während
die Ukraine Stück für Stück auseinander
genommen wird
eine Zusatzfrage von Ronny Schulz dazu
liegt noch ein Aspekt und noch eine
Ebene darüber hinaus
Einschätzung vielleicht von ihnen ist es
denn wenn es zu diesen Gesprächen kommen
sollte ist ja hypothetisch ist nicht der
aktuelle Situation aber ist es dann
fragt Ronny für die Ukraine möglich auch
langfristig den Frieden mit Russland zu
gewährleisten oder bräuchte es dafür
ihrer Meinung nach ein Systemwechsel in
Russland
diese Frage wird uns da Historiker
beantworten und der Historiker wird uns
gleichzeitig erklären dass es völlig
logisch war dass es so und so
ausgegangen ist das wissen wir nicht ja
wir stehen im Prinzip vor einer Türe die
wir halt geöffnet haben und die wissen
nicht was dahinter liegt es gibt sehr
viel Spekulationen nach wie vor wir
haben Pflegefall ein Hin und Her von
beiden Seiten operativen Erfolg der
Ukraine strategische Abnutzung der
Russen Erklärungen dass die eine Seite
ist nicht mehr lange durcheinander Seite
bis zum Schluss zu gehen die werden das
in den nächsten Wochen Monaten sehen man
muss auch ganz klar sagen es ist auch
die Entscheidung der Ukraine wie weit
sie also hier gehen möchte wie weit sich
aus in der Lage ist Entbehrungen und
Opfer zu übertragen auch die Bevölkerung
als solche ist und natürlich auch die
russische Seite ja die russische Kultur
die russische Geschichte zeigt dass die
Bevölkerung in Russland eher dazu neigt
in Zeiten der Krise eng zusammen zurück
Rücken und hinter dem Tyrannen zu stehen
egal wie brutale ist und was sie diese
diesen Krieg quasi weiterzuführen bis
zum Ende weil man sich davon erhofft
weil sie ein Überleben und sie dürfen
nicht vergessen die russische Propaganda
macht das sehr gut denn gesagt nicht wir
kämpfen gegen die Ukraine nein der
besten die EU den Auto kämpft gegen uns
sie sehen ja auf dieses Zelt dieses Z
steht ja nicht für Sabo Beda also rodner
für den Sieb es war daran das steht für
das russische Wort sadista also für das
Wort von Verteidigung das heißt sie
führen eine spezialoperation unter dem
Wort Verteidigung das ist so ganz
wichtig zu verstehen und das russische
narrativ zu betrachten und natürlich
werden auch in Russland viele Opposition
zu diesem Krieg sein und jede Mutter
weint und ihren Sohn und jedem Frauen
ihren Mann aber der Punkt ist solange es
nicht quasi diesen Oktober 1917 Moment
vergleichbar gibt wird was ich hier
dieser Krieg weitergeführt werden und
das bedeutet natürlich dass tausende
hunderttausende Soldaten und die Front
kommen und den Ukraine gegenüber stehen
die zu nehmen zwar immer noch tapfer und
die Moral hoch ist aber einfach
abgenutzt werden und das ist das Problem
dass wir haben
Verhandlungen haben gezeigt dass Kriege
lösbar sind und wenn man in die
Vergangenheit schaut dann sieht man das
Konflikte oft begonnen worden sind in
einer Euphorie des Glaubens von beiden
Seiten in zu gewinnen dann übergegangen
sind in eine zunehmende abnutzungsphase
wie in einem Boxkampf wo man sich
erschöpft dann in den Armen gelegen ist
und schlussendlich kam es dann durch
Schiedsrichter getrennt mehr oder
weniger zu einer möglicherweise
partsituation denken Sie an den
Koreakrieg zum Beispiel wo wir bis heute
eine Grenzlinie haben die noch immer die
Basis in dem Ergebnis des eigentlich
nicht beendeten Koreakrieges hat also
bis heute nicht beendet also es kann
durchaus sein dass auch so etwas wie die
Ukraine möglich ist momentan sagt nein
wir gehen es bis zum Schluss und nach
Russland ist nicht bereit auf
Verhandlungen sondern man sagt auch hier
wir werden unsere Ziele erreichen und
das ist die Situation die wir haben
ja der Status Quo von Oberst Markus
Reisner vom österreichischen Bundesheer
hier bei uns bei ZDF heute live ganz
herzlichen Dank dass Sie Ihre Einblicke
und auch ihre Expertise und Erfahrungen
hier bei uns geteilt haben
herzlichen Dank
danke auch an euch für die Kommentare
für die Fragen mit Blick auf die
aktuelle Situation des russischen
angriffskriegs gegen die Ukraine wir
werden da das wisst ihr hier bei ZDF
heute live auch in den nächsten Tagen
und Wochen über die Situation berichten
über die Situation weiter versuchen
aufzuklären Fakten zu schaffen und das
werden wir hier machen und dann würden
wir uns freuen wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder bei uns hiermit am
Start seit vielen Dank erstmal schön
Abend noch tschüss